>>Sparky: Ahoy me hearties, it's Wednesday
afternoon and welcome to your International
Talk Like a Pirate Day edition of
the Android Developers Office Hours EMEA edition.
[laughter]
>>Al: Argh!
>>Sparky: Drinking your first mate here. [Laughter]
>>Rich: [unintelligible chatter] Go Sparky!
Was it a late night last night?
>>Sparky: We're here to, we’re here to talk
about anything and everything related to Android
development. So, Rich, do you
want to give your standard disclaimer?
>>Rich: Yes. Questions asked in a pirate fashion
will be taken twice as seriously as any other
questions. We're wearing
clashing--rather matching t-shirts by accident.
It's certainly not planned and we won't be
talking about any future events product
releases hence events--anything that hasn't
been previously announced so please don't
ask, and that's the standard stuff.
[throbbing sound]
We've got quite a few people in the Hangout
with us today so I'll just run through, so
I'll say "Hello Al, good to see you here
today."
[crashing sound]
>>Al: Hey guys.
>>Nick: How are you today?
>>Rich: Is that Andrew Kelly next to Al there,
can we have a little a cursor on that?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Rich: Andrew Kelly, one man moderator machine,
good to see you--
[weird robotic noises]
[Unintelligible speech]
>>Rich: Um right--that window
[Laughter]
Marc: Argh!
Go to the next one. Hi, Marc as well, you
seem to know Sparky already. Paul, Richard
Thompson, Sparky of course and Tom. Glad to
see you all.
So before we kick off into the moderator today.
Obviously I'm here with Matt and Nick. You
must know these guys well.
>>Nick: Hello.
>>Matt: Hi.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Does anyone have any questions?
>>Marc: Yeah?
>>Rich: Go for it.
>>Marc: Shall we start?
>>Rich: Yeah yeah, if you've got a question
let's go for it.
>>Sparky: Please do.
>>Marc: Okay, then I'll start maybe. Yeah,
I'll ask question maybe about the assets--assets
folder on the library project. I
already asked that on the moderator regarding
the inheritance of the assets because we have
some, like for example, some
refuse--just some HTML files and some graphics--jpeg
files--not fancy stuff and we have for example
the library project with common
HTML files and common images and now we always
need to copy this assets over to the final
projects in order to get the stuff done
but I think this would be a really nice thing
to let the SDK tools do it because it is plain
simple to just copy the assets
over and do a simple inheritance and I'm just
asking why it isn't there because it's an
easy feature in my opinion.
>>Sparky: I think it's because assets are--it's
a folder location--
>>Marc: Exactly.
>>Sparky:--and it's relative to the directed
space location. If you read the documentation
carefully, it says that although raw
assets are not supported for library projects,
that raw resources are so anything you drop
into 'res'--
>>Marc: I know.
>>Sparky:--'res' raw should be okay. I mean,
there's really, apart from a minor API difference
in how you access it, there's not a
lot of difference between how you deal with
a raw resource versus an asset resource.
>>Al: I had a quick look around on this one
and there is a post from Zapia from ADT team
and basically what is says is that he's
not come up with enough time to work on an
intelligent solution for collisions between
assets that are in the library project and
assets which are in your actual application
project. So I think it's one of those things
that's on the list and just hasn't been
got round to yet.
>>Marc: Oh, okay. That would be a good explanation
because it's--I don't know where there's so
many collisions for example you
have the order of the library projects defined
and you have also the inheritance of the library
projects defined and I think
because it's just a simple folder with files
in it, you could just copy them over into
the right folder and you're done basically.
I don't know what they really mean with this
conflict--collisions.
>>Al: The problem comes if any of the libraries
require honor of an asset of a certain name
and if a library further up the chain
uses that same name for a different type of
asset you then get undefined behaviors in
one of your libraries because it doesn't know--it's
not getting the correct asset under that name.
So if you have a chat project that has a list
called "Blah" and something else that
has a graphic called "Blah" you'll find that
your chat library gets a graphic rather than
the list it expects and probably throw
out errors that you shouldn't normally see.
>>Marc: Okay.
>>Sparky: Sounds convincing to me.
>>Marc: I know we could just do this in the
raw resources and then we're done but basically
you can't access the raw resources so
[unintelligible] with a web view which is
plain awful, and if you do html pages, it's
a little bit harder.
>>Sparky: Hmm.
>>Marc: So in the assets folder you can just
load a web view called "file//assets" and
so on and then you can just load the html
file
and it loads the images automatically and
you're done and the other way around you would
have to--yeah, basically plain harder to do
with
the raw resources instead of using assets
for this case.
>>Al: If you want a quick and dirty hack,
you can use a class in a library file that
actually just contains a string which is the
HTML you want to render in the web view.
>>Marc: I know. I know. It’s basically what
I want to do now but it's basically a hack
to get to the assets in the correct--
>>Sparky: It's not really friendly to your
work flow is it?
>>Al: I'll put a link to the ADT group in
the comments for this Hangouts post and then
you can join and see if there's anything that
those guys can do for you in order to get
thing sped up and get you a solution.
>>Marc: Okay. Great.
>>Nick: Whenever you work around this, depending
on your build system, do you script it? It
might move the assets into the right
place for you of whatever you build.
>>Marc: So what now, we have the [unintelligible]
and we just have our projects and then every
project we copy over the first
asset folder from one library project then
the second assets folder, third one, basically
what the SDK tools should be doing.
>>Nick: You say you manually copy them or
you have a place in your ant build.
>>Marc: We manually copy them in our ant build
xml but of course now the problem is Eclipse
AD--the APK file built from
the [unintelligible] and the Eclipse APK differ
and it's not so easy to get the APK file to
the Eclipse file with
the right stuff. So right now we do it manually,
yeah. So basically that's what we're doing,
yeah, but it could be much easier with
some SDK tools update. I also had viewed some--there
was some patches online in Garrett before
the transition to the new Garrett
server and there were some patches on line
doing exactly this and updating the SDK tools,
but nobody 'res' them yet so they're not
in there yet.
>>Al: Are they in the new Garrett or they
still just in the old Garrett?
>>Marc: I think it was in the old Garrett.
>>Al: You might want to see who submitted
them and ask them to resubmit them to the
new Garrett because I think the old Garrett
has
been pretty much abandoned now.
>>Marc: I know. Okay, basically I will do
the hacking for now, but could be easier also
for other developers.
>>Nick: Okay, do you have any more live questions
in the Hangout or should we move onto the
moderator?
>>Sparky: I think we've got some more questions
in the moderator from people who are in the
Hangout. Paul is this yours about the
loaders do you want to ask that question?
[pause]
Maybe I will--
>>Rich: "Yes, but I have no microphone."
>>Sparky: No microphone okay. So so. Paul
Blundell in Liverpool wants to know: "Loaders
seem to the new 'in' thing to use when
developing an app, can we explain the use
cases and some of the benefits of using a
loader over the alternative?"
Mmm...anybody want to take that one? Should
I take it?
Basically the cool thing about loaders is
it's the simplest way to keep the contents
of your view in sync with its data source.
So, back before loaders, you had to actually
watch for callbacks and events regarding whether
or not your data had been changed
and updated and now the loaders will take
care of that for you. So you make a list view
or a list fragment and you implement the loader
interface and and say you have a content provider
that’s feeding data into that loader, you
stuff something new into the content
provider and your list view just magically
updates and you never have to worry about
callbacks or synchronization or anything like
that.
Anyone want to add anything to that?
>>Nick: With lifecycle events as well...I
think it really implements well with the life
cycles, it handles all your pauses and
resumes for you and it reconnects to the data
source and handles any changes so essentially
you write this code and it does all
that life cycle stuff for you so it's less
to maintain and debug.
>>Rich: I also think they are very good for
making sure your data was loaded off the main
thread as well. So, it all happens in the
background out of the main thread and keeps
your application UI running nice and smoothly
whilst the loading's happening as
opposed to --
>>Nick: Of course, most of what we're talk
about is specific to the cursor loader concrete
class, but it's also the loader
framework is more generic so you could extend
async loader to do other stuff as well which
isn't just [unintelligible] and you
still benefit from all the framework integration
as well. That has its benefits.
>>Rich: Okay. Hey Johan.
>>Nick: "Nice one," he says.
>>Sparky: "I'm convinced. I will use loaders
from now on. Thanks guys."
>>Rich: What's up next?
>>Sparky: Anyone want to jump in? Anyone want
to jump in with a question? Someone who just
came on? Johan do you have a question
for us?
>>Rich: You have no microphone--
>>Nick: We can't hear you--you need to--do
you have--
>>Rich: He's very good at mime.
>>Nick: Are you miming?
>>Johan: Yeah, yeah. I'm sorry. I thought
I had it on, I'm on now. Okay. Hey guys, just
want to say 'Hi.' I don't have any
particular thing I'm wrestling with, but maybe
I was thinking about one thing for in case
I have something like a bubble dialog
with small selection, of course you know that
there are some context menus or smaller--how
do you say it--what's the term?--maybe
small dialogs which hang to a component and
it shows little section of choices--
>>Matt: Bar---
>>Johan: But of course you have the popup
big views--what's kind of the way to go? I'm
tempted to just sort of go with the default
selection list mechanism--
>>Nick: Can you give me a little context about
what you're trying to do?
>>Johan: Come again mate?
>>Nick: Can you give me a little context about
what you're trying to show?
>>Johan: Well, it's basically I have a couple
of buttons on screen and if I press a button
there’s still a sub-selection to be done
before you go to the next activity, so I'm
kind of figuring out what's the best way to
go there. If I simply have a small pop up
menu which kind of hangs to that button --eh
the context, maybe the quick context is maybe
a bit of what I was looking at. So
what's the current design guideline on those
kind of contextual pop ups?
>>Nick: I would avoid a pop up if possible--
>>Johan: Okay.
>>Nick: Yeah, you can do a design where you
hit a button and it reveals another choice
below it, now that could work fine. But
yeah, the pop up menu which you're talking
about is kind of similar to the overflow menu,
you know where you hit a button and it
expands down, that's also an option, but another
option could to just sort of move on to the
next action and sort of default
it to one of the choices and allow the users
to change to the other choice.
>>Johan: Yep.
>>Nick: So I think just trying to avoid this
modal dialogs is generally a good design rule.
>>Johan: Okay, sounds fair. I think I'll go
with that to simply choose one of the options
and go for a selection for the other
options. Thanks so much.
>>Nick: Cool. You're welcome
>>Rich: And great work with V-hack Netherlands.
>>Johan: Yeah, it was good fun, good fun.
>>Nick: Maybe you can tell us a little bit
about it for those who aren't familiar?
>>Johan: Yeah, yeah, yeah. If you have some
time, I'll keep it short. A couple of user
groups have found out that Android is five
years old. It was introduced on fifth of November
in 2007 and a couple of user groups in Europe
in the world have pick it up and were
trying to celebrate it with hack-a-thons around
Europe. They tried one in Amsterdam and one
in Bremen, but there's still a couple of
hack-a-thon in Belgium, Berlin and Paris is
also joining and Ankara and a couple of others
and so we had the first in Amsterdam. We
had a couple of teams simply hacking away
in a couple categories defined by the international
group and other cities are joining in
as well and there's one big finale in London
right after Droidcon. We will have, uh, older,
older
winners from the local 'hack-a-thons' competing
with the teams from the UK so if you are living
in the UK you have a kind of
advantage
[laughter]
because you can simply join the final immediately.
No, it's going to be good fun with great prizes
so we got to give away some devices from Alcatel
so it's pretty good. Everybody
walked away with a tablet or a phone so everybody
had a good time.
>>Nick: Where's the best place to find out
more if people wanted to enter in?
>>Johan: I think it's simply vhackandroid.org.
I'll put it in the chat.
>>Nick: Excellent.
>>Rich: Thanks so much Johan.
>>Nick: Thanks so much for the summary. Sounds
like awesome hacker fun for everybody.
>>Rich: Yeah. All of us will be there.
>>Johan: Yeah, great fun.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Marc: I will have to go back to work soon,
so have fun and Sparky, have fun on Oktoberfest
on the first.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Dankeschön.
>>Marc: So have a good beer--maybe we'll see
each other there. So bye.
>>Sparky: Auf wiedersehen.
So, anybody else?
I see we have Andrew Kelly on the line. I
think you've got a question or two in the
moderator, did you want to ask those yourself?
>>Andrew: Yeah, I don't mind. Let me just
bring up the page. I guess this first one
was to do with taking pictures with the camera.
I was having some trouble getting the photos
to be stored in a private area of my app rather
than on the SD card and I was just
wondering if there was any special trick that
I needed to do to get that to happen?
>>Sparky: Are you talking about that you want
to put them on an internal storage?
>>Andrew: Yes.
>>Sparky: Ooo, ur. I honestly never tried
to do that.
>>Al: I think there's a problem with trying
to do that because the camera is a separate
application so any area that it would be
able to--that it would write to would have
to be a publicly writable area.
>>Andrew: There is but you can actually pass
where you launch the intent, the permission
to say--you can inherit the permissions
of the parent app so I was thinking that might
give the camera app permission to write to
my private storage.
>>Sparky: But you would still have to make
the final roll writable---
>>Nick: I think the grant permission just
grants permission to read--I don't think it
can grant permission to write, can it there?
>>Andrew: Yeah, there's two. There's a grant
to write and a grant to read URI.
>>Rich: Have you checked on Stack Overflow
>>Andrew: But they don't seem to work. There's
no URI.
>>Rich: And there was not help on Stack Overflow
on that one?
>>Andrew: Eh, no. Not really.
>>Rich: Well, could ask the question---
[soft chuckling]
>>Andrew: That's why I came to you guys.
[warbling voices, indistinct chatter]
>>Sparky: I think every example that I've
seen just writes to the SD card because that's
the standard media repository.
>>Andrew: I don't want people to tweet with
the pictures that they've taken once they've
taken them from this free game that I'm
writing.
>>Sparky: Now, you can, if you only want a
small picture--you could get a thumbnail back
and just not store it. In fact my little
demo app does that.
>>Andrew: Nah, I'm after the big picture I'm
afraid.
>>Nick: What about taking the photo and then
copying it or moving it into your--
>>Andrew: That was my sort of last resort
if there was no other way.
>>Nick: Not sure if this is a solution, but
if there is a--I haven't used this for grant
write permission before--if that's not
working for you maybe you can send us link
to [unintelligible] with your question and
we can take a look into it further.
>>Andrew: Okay, cool.
>>Nick: Anyone else use the grant write permission?
No?
>>Nick: Not in this case?
[laughter]
>>Andrew: Trust me to find it.
>>Matt: Do you have any more questions? I
think Sparky said there might be one or two?
>>Andrew: A couple--there was one about setting
the wallpaper. I was hoping to not have to
request a permission to set a wallpaper
and to actually just sort of launch the wallpaper
intent somehow and to be able to pass an image
to that they can then say "yes" or
"no." Is that something that's possible?
>>Rich: Not that I know of, no.
>>Matt: I don't know of any either.
>>Rich: You can either send them to the wallpaper
chooser or you can use the intent but you
can't combine the two--to my knowledge.
>>Andrew: Yes, so I can register to be one
of the icons inside the wallpaper chooser
but I still kind of need the set wallpaper
permission to do the setting.
>>Rich: That's correct as far as I know. I've
never seen anyone---it does seem like a work
around security to me.
>>Andrew: Yeah, well I was trying to think
if there might be a way that the wallpaper
chooser, when it launches, I can set the
image in a sort of "on results" and then the
wallpaper chooser can then sort of do something
with the permission--like show it to
the user or whatever.
>>Rich: If your app is trying to set wallpapers,
why don't you just go ahead and use the permission?
>>Andrew: Well I've been watching my Google
IO "Reduce your number of permissions" video.
>>Rich: But we'd rather you were explicit
about the actions you were going to do as
opposed to working around them and to try
and hide
the permissions.
>>Andrew: Well, I'm not trying to hide--I'm
trying to be the receiver of the intent's
pay. I'm just--one of the things, just like
the sort of live wallpaper gallery. My app
can also show you a list of images that come
from Flickr or somewhere like that. You
choose the image from my stream and then it's
up to you to say set wall paper, as a user,
to make it turn into the background.
>>Rich: Yeah. Okay.
>>Andrew: So rather than kind of circumvent,
I was just trying to alleviate the need for
me to actually set permission.
>>Rich: But you've tried and it doesn't work
I take it without the permission?
>>Andrew: Yes. Yeah.
>>Nick: It definitely in the source of wallpaper
lists, there's a [unintelligible] that pops
up and says "wallpaper gallery "
[intelligible] on that list, I've seen apps
do that.
>>Rich: yeah, I think that's what he's saying.
>>Andrew: Yeah, so I'm in the list but I still
need to set wallpaper permission to set the
wallpaper.
>>Matt: The impression I got from the IO talk
was [unintelligible] refuse permissions that
you need in terms of ones that you
actually require versus ones that you're just
doing as a 'nice to have 'em'. I mean, my
[AdMob] is a prime example of that. If you
need a lot of advertising it would make a
lot of sense but it's up to you as a developer
to allow that or not. And yeah, I think
games are the worst for that. There are some
games out there which have a horrific amount
of permissions that really aren't needed.
So I
think at the end of the day you've got a perfect
kind of use case for it, so I don't think
any user would sit there and see
that permission and get up and run away scared
so that's the main thing.
>>Andrew: Cool. Okay.
>>Rich: So regardless of whether you've arranged
it to be in that list, you still would have
the ability to set wallpapers, right?
>>Andrew: Yes. I've got a button inside my
app that when you're viewing a photo, you
can click that button and it says, you know,
'set wallpaper’ and it just sets it in the
background so when you actually exit the app,
the wallpaper is there.
>>Rich: Yeah. Fair enough. But no, we don't
know a way of not doing that.
>>Andrew: Cool.
>>Rich: Okay.
>>Matt: Anyone want to ask the next question?
>>Rich: Yeah--
>>Nick: Hey [Rand] I didn't see you sneak
into the Hangout.
>>Rand: Hi. How are you doing Rich and Nick?
>>Rich: Pretty good. Nick has got us together--he's
got his Android with him as well.
>>Nick: Yeah, we're good.
>>Rand: Actually, I got a couple of questions
if you guys got time.
>>Nick: Please.
>>Rand: Okay. One should be pretty easy, I
am trying to do audio manager set microphone
muted?
>>Nick: Uh huh.
>>Rand: Microphone. The problem is that API
works on some devices and doesn’t work on
other devices, and other than try and pick
on
all devices I don't know how can I tell in
advance what device will it work on what and
what API should I use?
>>Al: Is that microphone muted?
>> Unknown Male: Are the devices under the
same company or is it dif--you know same company
for one device the works and others
that don't?
>>Rand: I can tell you on that on a Galaxy
S2, it doesn't work; on a Galaxy Nexus, it
doesn't work; on a Galaxy S3, it does work;
on
some HTC that we've tested, it works. I can
do a whole list. I don't have the list right
here in front of me, but on some devices
it worked, some it didn't. The Galaxy S2 the
US model it works just fine, the European
model it doesn't work. Things like that. I
can see the link. Let me see what they're
saying at Stack Overflow.
>>Al: There's a--one of the answers there
which is an interesting one--is simulating
a mute button on a handset being pressed.
>>Rich: Yeah, I see that. It's just that works
for all of them, it's unfortunate--
>>Nick: It's interesting it doesn't work on
the Galaxy Nexus, which was my big surprise.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Sparky: I wouldn't--I would probably draw
a distinction between muting the input for
an application versus muting input for a
phone call as well. I think any time that
you begin talking about a telephony stream
it just gets that much more complicated.
>>Rand: I'm not talking about a telephony
stream. Um, just trying the mute the microphone.
I'm doing how to record, well I'm doing
SIP Voice over IP phone call, but that's my
application and it works on the media stream
not the telephony stream.
>>Sparky: Yeah. Hmm. Hmm.
>>Al: Wouldn't Android think it's the same
thing though?
>>Rand: What?
>>Al: Wouldn't Android think it's the same
thing whether it's a VOIP call or a standard
call? It's the same API's really.
>>Rand: It's the same API when we're talking
about the Audio manager but first you set
the audio manager and then audio stream to
work on whatever it is you want it to work
on.
>>Al: When this app does the volume, can you
use, you know, just the regular volume for
that? There are some phones however that
that doesn't work with. I remember that issue
coming up when I was reading about it. I don't
think it's really going to matter whether
it's a VOIP
call or whether it's a a standard call. It's
the same --basically the same things, so--
>>Rand: Oh, as far as for the Android OS,
it doesn't know that I am doing a VOIP call.
My application is doing all that stuff,
I'm not using the Android OS SIP interface
or anything like that. I just--I need--I opened
the microphone to try for the audio
packets, I do all the G729 compression, all
that stuff. So far as for Android, it doesn't
know what I am doing with the audio
unit--I'm recording.
>>Rich: The API doc says you shouldn't be
using this method. So the hack into the Stack
Overflow questions to get the manager to--the
platform audio manager to mute itself--by
pretending to be headset actually is reasonable,
uh, the API doc says, "This method should
only
be used by applications that are replacing
platform wide management of audio settings."
>>Rand: Oh, okay.
>>Rich: So if you're replacing the entire
audio layer platform, then maybe you can use
it, because you're the only person trying
to
control it I guess. But otherwise, getting
the --I don't know if there's another method
to ask the platform to mute the microphone
but faking the handset mute, which asks the
platform to mute it, doesn't seem like a bad
solution.
It would be interesting to have a look into
the source code for it and see what it actually
does.
>>Nick: And if you're in control of what you
with audio stream and auto compression and
sending it down your SIP channel, can you
just not send it?
>>Rand: Yeah, that's a work around. I just
want to avoid that question, because all the
CODEC is done in NDK, is done in with it
down there. I want the application to catch
whether I'm muted or not muted; to display
the right user interface to the user; stuff
like that. If I don't have any choice, then
yeah, I will do it down there in the CODEC
itself --I will just ignore that information,
I will not
compress it and I will not send it. But I'd
rather to have it done --to do just an application
layer and first save logic from the
CODEC which is complex enough as it is and
again to be synchronized with what the user
sees. If he sees his microphone muted or not
muted and so on.
Okay. I guess there is no easy path here.
>>Nick: Rich is [looking into] the source
code.
>>Rand: Okay. Can I get another one or is
there somebody else?
>>Al: I've had quick look in the source code
and basically the mute microphone calls down
to native codes that can vary by
platform.
>>Rand: Mmm. Okay. So I have to implement
entire audio management system for the entire
system?
>>Rich: You mute your own stream so you don't
send it through when it's muted.
>>Rand: Yeah. I'll look in on it.
>>Rich: Thanks.
>>Nick: And as always, my kind of first reaction
here is platform specific like it worked with
one--
>>Rand: All right. I think London just fell.
>>Al: Yep. They seem pretty frozen.
>>Rand: No, I'm still alive.
>>Al: London drops off every now and again.
>>Rand: The Bridge is not that strong sometimes.
>>Al: Have we got Sparky?
>>Sparky: Are you saying that London Bridge
is falling down?
>>Al: Arrr, we are me heartie!
[Laughter]
>>Rand: It's hard but they build it really
fast quite surprisingly.
>>Al: I'm not singing the next part of that
song because calling you my fair lady could
be taken very much the wrong way. ARRR!
>>Sparky: Should we move on to another question?
Does anyone else have want to ask some?
>>Rand: I've got one--we are thinking about
develop--
[pause, video and audio cut out]
a device and we are thinking on doing a native
versus web if you see what I mean. Web view
I mean. The
web view versus Java.
>>Rich: HTML 5?
>>Rand: Yeah.
>>Al: Read Marc Thibault's comments--I think
that's all that needs to be said.
[laughter]
>>Rand: Actually one of the Facebook guys
just posted in W3org all the problems that
they had with HTML 5. I can look up for it
if
you want.
>>Al: One of the biggest ones seems to be
that people write HTML 5 for mobile assuming
that it's going to be the same as [est Top]
and
have the same processing power and it always
falls short.
>>Rand: Um--
>>Unknown male speaker: It's not a lot of
processing, it's more like acquiring your
information from a server and basically
showing it to the user. It's not a big app,
it's a smaller . It's not something that needs
to use a lot of resources but you know they
want
to make it fast and work on both the desktop
and the mobile.
>>Nick: If you want to go fast, use Java.
>>Al: That's a bit weak in mobile--
>>Sparky: If you mean run fast, but I think
he means write it fast.
>>Rand: Yeah, to write it. In development
fast, but to work fast--to work fast I know
I need native.
>>Sparky: You know, I would say for a quick
and dirty first draft to see if it actually
works--yeah--go ahead and use a web view.
Uh, but I wouldn't pour a whole ton of resources
trying to make a super good UI in a web view.
You know it's like, if you just want basic
form, get a little data--you'll display it
but don't--don't expect too much from it I
would say.
>>Unknown male speaker: Okay, what is this,
like when did web view start in Android versions?
Which API did it start from?
>>Sparky: Ooh--
>>Unknown male speaker: [Must have come from
the same cupboard]
>>Al: It was in one point oh, so I think--
>>Unknown male speaker: So it doesn't really
matter? Yeah, that covers it. Just want to
make sure it's a Gingerbread and above.
>>Al: Definitely a Gingerbread and above.
>>Unknown Male speaker: They say Gingerbread
holds the--
>>Sparky: Actually my little RSS reader sample
that I threw together last spring, it runs
all the way back to one point six and I think
it
actually works on a G1 and it uses a web view.
>>Al: Web view is listed as being around since
API level one so it's a good safe bet, the
only thing I'd say, it's a bit of a
risky pass unless they are willing to throw
away the whole app if they want to expand
the functionality. That's the danger of
starting off doing it in HTML 5 and then you
end up with bits of organic growth and you
end up finding that you've written a whole
app in HTML 5 and you're hitting the performance
barriers.
>>Nick: Or you turn around [unintelligible]
and say I need to spend a month to get back
to where you already are up to--
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Yeah, that's why I was sort of careful
to say don't expect too much from your HTML
5 version and don't pour too many
resources into trying to gold plate it.
>> Matt: I think one of the biggest risks
as well is it's very easy to sit there and
develop this sites on a desktop browser and
then kind of look at it in Chrome on the mobile
device and see it's okay, carry on, and then
when you actually move it to web view
then suddenly thing start breaking. It's something
I've seen numerous people do on the T.V. site
and it's kind of heartbreaking to
see--they get so far but then it just has
to kind of stop and have to go over everything
to do it exactly the same.
>>Sparky: That said, I suppose if you don't
try to go too fancy with the HTML 5, if you
really stick to basic HTML and not a lot of
JavaScript, client side stuff, you know, there's
a certain limit on how much damage you can
do to yourself.
[laughter]
>>Al: And limit your use of CSS. There's a
lot of things you can do in CSS that tend
to be pretty processor heavy these days.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Well you know, now
phones are also getting faster so I think
you need to take that into consideration.
You
know it's quite funny that some phones are
better than some desktops and laptops.
>>Al: You ought to see these statistics for
the number of people who actually own phones
like that. They're a very limited unless you're
saying
Gingerbread phones are predominate at the
moment and they tend to be at least a generation
behind the current kind of Ice Cream Sandwich
and Jellybean phones are.
[children playing in background]
>>Unknown Speaker: Well I guess when Ice cream
becomes the---
[pause, video cuts out]
>>Al: --a bit more power but the other thing
is there's always going to be a need for budget
phones and people will buy budget phones
so you're always going to fighting against
that kind of trend.
>>Sparky: I mean, you look at some of the
other companies in the electronics space and
they figured out years ago that basically
at
any given point and time, you've got certain
price buckets that people will buy from. Now
say with personal computers, you've got your
under five hundred bucks, your thousand buck,
two thousand, three thousand-- and they will
build the best device that they can
build to fit that price bucket so no matter
what, you're always going to have a phone
maker who's trying to hit a fifty dollar
price point and a hundred dollar price point
and so if you want the mass adoption of Ice
Cream Sandwich, you've got to have the
hardware capability to run Ice Cream Sandwich
shrunk down to the point where you can actually
put it into a hundred dollar form
factor.
>>Unknown male: There is such thing as one
hundred dollar phone? I don't really know
any of those, but that's for a
different day--discussion.
>>Sparky: Actually that was--this was in the
news maybe a year ago that there was a line
of Android phones, I think maybe
Gingerbread that was being sold in Kenya--
>>Rich: Yep.
>>Sparky:--that was about a hundred bucks.
>>Unknown Male speaker: Really? Wow!
>>Sparky: Subsidized--a hundred bucks.
>>Nick: They have them in the UK for one hundred
pounds, right so that was like--
>>Rich: Yeah the Huaweis--
>>Nick: The [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Which range in Kenya for about a hundred
dollars--sixty pounds.
>>Unknown Male speaker: I know here it is
quite a--for example the HTC Wildfire, the
old one, costs-what is it-I think it's around
two hundred
fifty dollars. So we are a bit far off on
that.
>>Sparky: That's because all the prices look
bigger when you read them from right to left.
[laughter]
>> Matt: They arrr.
>>Sparky: That really wasn't funny.
>>Al: For that one you should walk the plank.
>>Sparky: Arrr.
[laughter]
>>Nick: Are there any more questions in the
moderator or live? There's one in the G+ chat
we wanted---
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Let's see what we've got in the
moderator--we've got--we did that one. Loaders--we
did that one--
"When might we expect a public release of
the Google Play Services--" Yes, moving on.
Uh--
[laughter]
Wallpaper--
>>Al: The answer's always soon.
>>Rich: Definitely soon.
>>Sparky: Were you looking at the heterogeneous
[unintelligible] question?
>>Nick: I was looking at--there was one in
the G force comments from Kristal O'Hare asking
when and if you could use alternative
pay providers on Google Play.
So--the answer is see the content policy.
Content policy says you must always use Google
Play payment provider, which is Wallet, except
for and it makes two exceptions. The first
one is if you're paying for physical goods,
so concert tickets and like that.
>>Rich: It's quite the opposite--you can't
use Google Wallet to sell those.
>>Nick: Yeah, then you have to use your own
pay provider and the second one--it says--I'm
just going from memory here--if you're
buying additional content which available
beyond the application--I think an example
there is mp3, Amazon mp3 where you buy access
to an mp3 track and then you can then access
that track on your iPad,
>>Rich: Same for Kindle as well, you might
read it on here, you might read it on your
Kindle, but it also then says you must not
use this to get around using Google Play payments.
So you can't just suddenly decide to you want
to make your digital assets, or whatever
inside your game, run a website so you don't
have to use our payment mechanism.
>>Nick: Plus it comes down to our policy team's
interpretation of this fairly nebulous description
of additional content and
available beyond. I think the key thing is
if the primary use case is that you're buying
something and you're going to use it
in the application and always in the application
and there may be some other method to access
in the browser, but you never expect
someone to use it, then that--I would consider
that trying to work around the policy and
that probably wouldn't be allowed.
So those are two cases I know where you can
provide your own payment provider.
>>Rich: Definitely it's always safest to use
Google Play payments.
>>Andrew: How does carrier billing fit into
that? Does that just come up as another option
in Google Wallet next to your credit
card?
>>Rich: Forty percent of Google Play users
can access carrier billing, in many countries
in the world, many operators and yeah it
just comes up as another option.
>>Andrew: Cool.
>>Nick: Same with gift cards in the US and
if you buy access and you get this kind of
balance that you get with it so it just comes
up as other options with which you can use
to pay for the goods.
>>Rich: Which reminds me, if you're going
to buy a Nexus 7, do it very very soon. I
think the original twenty-five dollar credit
promotion
is expiring at the end of September. So you
need to receive your Nexus 7 --
>>Unknown male speaker: Is this twenty-five
dollars only for US Nexus 7 or also Europe
ones?
[several talking at once]
>>Rich: UK, France, Germany--all the official
countries that were supported got it--Canada--
>>Rand: You need to add US credit card to
get those twenty-five dollars.
>>Rich: No, in the UK, it was a UK credit
card; in France it was a French--
>>Rand: Maybe the UK [mumbles] yeah.
>>Rich: In the large countries, you use your
local country credit card and get your stuff
that way.
>>Andrew: It worked fine here in Australia.
>>Rand: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: I can't tell what he's saying.
>>Nick: You used it now twice right? With
the replacement Nexus 7?
>>Rand: Yeah, I did it twice, yeah.
[laughter]
>>Rich: He did it twice huh---
>>Rand: Let me show you, just a second.
[laughter]
>>Nick: He dropped his one week old Nexus
7--
>>Rich: Ahh. So he had to buy another one.
>>Unknown male speaker: Well I got the Nexus
7 which is a pretty nice ..I messed with--Oh--two
Nexus 7--well--
>>Rand: Yeah, well, this one is broken. Ah,
you can't see it really. There's part of the
glass--there's part of it's broken. But I
couldn't resist--I swapped the covers.
>>Nick: Aw, you swapped the white back. Nice.
>>Rand: Yeah, I had to stay with the white.
>>Nick: So what are you going to do with broken
one, does it still work except for the screen?
>>Rand: Yeah, it works, the screen works.
This is the broken one. It's just broken and
the touch doesn't work all around the
screen, so I guess I'll just make it, so you
know, maybe an ADK controller or a music streamer
or something.
I'll make use of it.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Well, they're starting
to [unintelligible] in Israel for Asus, so
maybe they'll be able to fix it for you or
at least some..
>>Rand: Actually there is an Asus importers
in Israel and they provide service for the
Nexus 7 right now.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Really? Wow.
>>Rand: And uh the International Warranty
works so they accept it, but that's very nice.
But then again I couldn't resist, I just got
a
new one.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: That's the nice thing about the
lower price point, it almost comes down to
the "oh what the heck, I'll just buy it"
level.
>>Rand: Well it makes it less painful.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Well it's really cheap--eh--not--
>>Rand: Not expensive is the word you were
looking for.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Yeah. Where did you
buy it from?
>>Rand: Directly from Google Play.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: But from UK or US
?
>>Rand: US.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Hmm.
>>Rand: I got an office there and cards and
all that stuff so--
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Well I use other methods,
but I'll not explain for today.
>>Rand: All right. [laughter] Don't go there.
Um, can I have another question about some
issue that I'm facing with?
>>Sparky: Yes, please.
>>Rand: Thank you.
I'm trying to do my own exception catcher.
To catch all on card exceptions--if my application
will crash--my applications never
crash but IF it will happen and it will crash,
I'll be to catch it and maybe recover from
it without the user noticing and all that
stuff and if I can't recover, I want to grab
all the logs, I want to grab the system logs,
I want to grab my own DP or something
and send it over to my CRM server.
The thing that I've seen is that when I have
my own handler which implements an on card
exception handler. I'm using the old school
'set default' on caught exception. My handler
is being called when there is an exception
and I can run my code, but for some reason
I either need to re-throw the exception and
then Android always will kill my application
or I need to do system exit myself, and
kill the application otherwise it looks like
for some reason the UI thread it just gets
stuck. It doesn't go back to the event loop
or something. I don't know.
So is there a work around around it or in
such a case I have to shut down my process
and restart it?
>>Al: It's probably worth saying at this point,
Jellybean has tighter restrictions on what
logging information you can access. Um,
so--
>>Rand: My logs only.
>>Al: Oh.
>>Rand: I'm not looking for any other application
log or--looking for my log, my own internal
DB and stuff that I'm saving. Only my
information.
>>Al: You mentioned the system logs you were
thinking of accessing so you're okay without
doing that.
>>Rand: Yeah. Right now I'm simply reading
the log starting with Jellybean, and the log
will only show me my log lines and I'm fine
with it. I have no problem. That's great.
>>Al: Cool.
>>Rich: So, how are you going to know--I mean,
what kind of--
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Ugh. I think London
the bridge is falling again. Oh maybe not.
>>Rich: Oh--hello?
>>Rand: We've got London twice here.
>>Rich: Oh my God. We should have gone back
to the studio, but we didn't. We've got a
black curtain, but we're not inside the
studio today.
Yeah, you're trying to catch an exception
from somewhere in your application, how do
you know you're going to be able to recover
from it without having to kill the app?
>>Rand: I can--first, I can query the application
and understand which model had that exception,
maybe I can just restart that
model or maybe I cannot recover and I have
to shut down my application and restart. But
in many cases, I can recover, for example
if the user presses a button and for some
reason I can't process that event--instead
of crashing the application I can just display
a simple toast message or open windows saying,
"Sorry we cannot do this in that--
[pause, video cuts out briefly]
>>Rich: I think your app is going to be in
a slightly unstable state at that point and
the recommendation we have to pass on:
either close down or pass it on to the default
exception handler to finish off cleaning up.
It's just to be assumed that you're not
going to be able to recover from this position.
If you--
>>Rand: So that's the basic assumption that
I won't be able to recover and--
>>Rich: This is an uncaught exception. You
can deal with this exception, you should deal
with it in the place where it was
originally caught and carry on. But you've
jumped from the main thread now, the main
thread's gone to the exception handler and
the
exception handler is now working away at just
logging this and killing the app so the system
can continue.
>>Andrew: There is a tool called Jira Mobile
Connect which is written by the guys at Atlassian
here in Sydney which is a sort of
open sourcing that does exactly what this
guy's talking about. It sort of catches exceptions
and then lets the user leave a message
for the developer staff and then it goes back
and hooks into Jira and the tracking tool
and keeps logs for you [unintelligible].
>>Rich: And it will close down, right?
>>Andrew: Yeah.
>>Rich: It's just a nice way of tracking the
exception when it does.
>>Nick: Here's what I know of--
>>Andrew: Yeah.
>>Rand: Yeah. I used to use [Acron]--just
trying to improve it and avoid having my application--
>>Rich: Sorry. The thing to do is when you
log it make sure you get the details of it
and make sure you catch it in the right place
next time just do an update to patch and catch.
'Cause as soon as the application is leaving
its running state to go into the
exception handling state, it's on its way
down.
>>Rand: I understand.
>>Nick: I think [unintelligible] the exception
handler, I mean that's the thing which tears
down, right? And cleans up after you.
Hold on to reference to that call in--
>>Rich: You have to pass it on to the exception
handler after you're done to finish off. Or
close it up yourself. I think the
system wants you to--
>>Al: Augh. They're gone again. The uncaught
exception handler at javadocs for Android
actually saves a notification when the
application has been terminated. I don't think
there's anyway you can recover, but what you
might want to think about is you could
try using a broadcast intent loop so in your
uncaught exception handler you could fire
off a broadcast intent and have a broadcast
intent receiver which restarts your app.
>>Rand: Yeah, I'm trying to do that, but in
some cases even my intent is not being broadcasted
unless I kill my own process.
>>Rich: Have a service to restart your app
again. Umm I don't know why. If we drop out
more frequently, we might actually get three
or four at one time. [laughs]
>>Matt: Nice.
>>Nick: I don't know what all of these drop
outs are for.
>>Rich: Um,okay. Is Sparky still with us?
>>Rand: No, they dropped out.
>>Rich: One, two, three, four, five, six--
[video cuts out briefly]
>>Al: There's a follow up question about the
payments in Google Market. The situation the
guy's given is, if he has an existing web
based game and he's developing an Android
client for it, and wants to allow people to
purchase digital goods for use in that web
based game but via the Android app, do you
see that as allowed or not. I don't know if
you guys can actually answer that one or
whether you should just refer straight to
the Play store guys.
>>Rich: Yeah, that is one of the things we
refer to the Play store guys to get a definitive
answer on.
>Nick: Yeah, it comes down to where it falls
under that definition of digital content doesn't
it? Which I'm not in a place to rule
on.
[chuckles]
>>Rich: Yeah, and if they think that the majority
of people are just--You're getting [unintelligible]
from the Play store--installing the
app from the Play store getting--seeing it
at the play store, downloading it and only
using it on the device then they may
consider that the web version is a work around.
And why wouldn't you just our in app payments
for purchase those items anyway?
Why would you want to work around it when
you're getting the distribution and the extra
users?
>>Al: His thing is that his primary game is
already web based; the Android app is an extension
to that so--
>>Rich: He can choose in that case not to
have any payment at all and then people can
buy their things on the web if they want but
he still shouldn't link back to the web version
to buy those things. It would be the safe
option. If he does do it the other way
around and the Play team decides it is infringement-they
can just take you down. Or he can request
support. He can go through
other channels and ask for support, file a
ticket and hopefully they'll make a decision
before he actually builds the app.
Okay. Hello, welcome back Sparky--[unintelligible]
We've had more drop outs than--
>>Sparky: Yeah, it's not too often that I
lose my connection here, it's usually more
often the case that I simply can't make it
in
the first place.
>>Rich: You just went off so you could take
your pirate hat off.
>>Nick: There's five minutes left today. Are
there any more questions we want to go through
today, live in the room or in the
moderator?
>>Sparky: Did you answer any questions in
the moderator while I was out?
>>Nick: I don't think so.
>>Rich: We didn't answer well, we just left
the community up to it.
>>Sparky: Oh okay.
>>Al: Here's a quick question. Nick, when
can I see the next installment of your redesigned
broadcast on YouTube?
>>Nick: Well Al--[laughter]--thanks for asking.
For those who don't know, we've gotten up
a new show called Android Design in
Action, where we take an existing application
which is reviewed in the App Clinic on a Friday
and give it a re-imagining applying
Android Design Principles to it. You can tune
in every Tuesday at three-thirty GMT and so
yeah, it'll be back next week.
>>Rich: Thanks Nick.
>>Nick: Do you watch it Al?
>>Al: I do watch it. I'm looking forward to
it. I particularly like the brown and orange
coloring to the stopwatch app this week.
I've always tried to stick close to the HOLO
colors of using blue so it's quite good to
see something that's drifted a bit farther
apart.
>>Nick: Yeah, Roman did a great job on that.
It was beautiful. I think he [unintelligible]
photo there and we had about a
hundred comments saying "Please, where can
I get that app?"
[laughter]
>>Nick: They like good designers.
>>Unknown Male speaker: Well, I--
>>Nick: We shouldn't let them have anything
>>Rich: A redesign of the ultimate stopwatch--
>>Nick: Oh I see.
>>Rich: Yeah, yeah, since you guys didn't
redesign it for me.
[laughter]
>>Al: Was that payback for not implementing
rich notifications, Rich?
>>Rich: It might be I don't know. I just took
out my name and ignored the rest of the app.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: I also wanted to tell
you, in Israel they're started doing a--I
don't know in which language they are doing
it--but they're doing reviews on start ups
on Google+ every Wednesday at--
>>Rand: Ido. Ido Green is doing it.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: Yeah. Does he do it
in English or Hebrew?
>>Rand: Most of it is in English like--it's
going to be eighty percent English, twenty
percent Hebrew. He took the first shot two
weeks ago I think.
>>Rich: Cool.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: So if anybody wants
to watch it is on Wednesday at two P.M. Israel
time so that's basically twelve GMT or
something like that.
>>Rand: Two-thirty.
>>Nick: Cool.
We're almost going to a, you know, full schedule
of programming of developers-- if you go to
Google+ live there's tons and tons of
programming popping up every day.
>>Rand: Right.
>>Matt: Any other questions?
>>Unknown speaker: Are you coming to Israel
again? I thought Rich said something didn't
you about coming again in October?
>>Rich: That was for another event and I was
going to be in Israel at the same time, but
unfortunately the other event has been
canceled so I won't be going to Israel in
October. But I have to get back before the
end of the year. Travel around Europe a bit
more as well.
The next things we will be at are Droidcon
London and Droidcon Amsterdam I think we'll
be attending but maybe it's be better
if--it's dead set--we're seeing what we can
do. Amongst our project work and other things.
It's always good to come out and--
>>Unknown male speaker: All right.
>>Rand: We're planning Andcon on October twenty-third.
>>Rich: Andcon?
>>Matt: Andcon?
>>Rand: Yeah, we can't use Droidcon here so
we use Andcon. We had one in June and we're
going to have another one in October
twenty-third probably.
>>Rich: Excellent.
>>Al: Droidcon London's the twenty-fifth through
the twenty-seventh of October so it will be
a busy week.
>>Rand: Yeah.
>>Al: It might also be worth mentioning that
on developers.google.com/live if you put /android
after that you can get just the
Android events.
>>Matt: Yeah. That'd be good.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Andrew: So what was that link again?
>>Rich: Can you put it in the chat?
>>Nick: Developers.google.com/live and if
you want just Android you add /android.
>>Al: I'll put it in the chat.
>>Matt: Are we done?
>>Nick: So unless there's any burning issues
in the room, brings us to the end of our time
today. Nothing going once--
>>Sparky: There's a couple of questions left
in the moderator but either I don't know the
answer or I already answered them and if
if the person who asked a question once wants
to talk about it on the air then just let
us know offline and we can copy the
questions over to next week or something like
that.
>>Nick: Sorry about that problem with us dropping
in and out today. We'll try and find out what's
going on--
>>Rich: We'll try and go back to the studio
again next week.
>>Nick: Yeah. If the quality was worse this
week, we were in the studio last week it was
a bit better then.
>>Unknown Male Speaker: When you were in the
studio, you dropped a bit less than what happened
today.
>>Al: Video quality seems a little lower and
blurs particularly when you move for me , so--
[laughter]
Thanks guys!
>>Nick: We're a bit unpredictable.
>>Al: Yes, you scurvy dogs!
[laughter]
>>Rich: Why are pirates called pirates?
>>Nick: They just Arrr.
>>Rich: 'Cause they just Arr.
[laughter]
>>Al: And on that I think you've sunk the
ship.
>>Nick: So thanks for tuning us in and keep
the questions coming into the moderator for
next week and we will see you same time
next week.
>>Al: Thanks guys.
>>Sparky: Cheers.
>>Unknown male speaker: Cheers.